يعد التباعد الاجتماعي والسفر الجوي
متناقضين من حيث الأشكال الطويلة التي
تبخر مساحة الأرجل
والسفر الجوي المتكئ غير
مناسب بشكل خاص لواقعنا الجديد في فيروس كورونا
، فقد ترك الوباء السفر العالمي في حالة
توقف افتراضي ومن الواضح أن
الطريقة التي نطير بها يجب أن تتغير من قبل
سيشعر الركاب بالراحة في
العودة إلى الأجواء الودية على كتلة
قبل الأزمة ، كان هناك هذا
الدافع الهائل لزيادة السعة على متن الطائرة
مما دفع الجمهور الطائر إلى التقارب أكثر من أي وقت مضى
الآن يجب على شركات الطيران أن تتبنى
العكس تمامًا ولكن على الأقل
يبدو أن المقعد الأوسط سيبقى
فارغًا على الأرجح  في المستقبل المنظور ، على
الرغم من أن ذلك سيجعل من المستحيل تقريبًا
على شركات الطيران جني الأموال ،
يقول الرئيس التنفيذي لاتحاد النقل الجوي الدولي ألكسندر دي جوري إيه سي كيه إن أسعار التذاكر يجب أن ترتفع في
هذه الظروف ، ولا يوجد لي
قادر على الطيران وكسب المال  على هذه حول
هذا ولكن هذا يعني شيئين إما
يمكننا التقديم أو لدينا  لزيادة
سعر التذاكر بنسبة لا تقل عن 50 إلى
100 في المائة ، لذا فإن نهاية
السفر الرخيص لجميع شركات الطيران تعمل على
تكثيف الاحتياطات الأخرى بشأن
أقنعة JetBlue Air Canada الكورية و Lufthansa
ستكون إلزامية طوال مدة
الرحلات التي تحددها طيران الإمارات
يتم توزيع الأمتعة المحمولة على الأساسيات فقط في صناديق بينتو ستيل
لتقليل الاتصال حتى تمت إزالة المجلات الموجودة على متن الطائرة
من
الجيوب الخلفية للمقاعد في حالة حملها
للفيروس ، وتوقع رؤية أطقم المقصورة يرتدون
أقنعة وأردية حماية شخصية كاملة
قد تكون المعدات هي
ترتيب اليوم وتقول الخطوط الجوية القطرية إنها
تجري فحوصات حرارية لطاقمها
على الرغم من كل هذه الإجراءات ،
يعتقد
رئيس شركة إكسبيديا أن الطيران والتباعد
الاجتماعي لا
يتوافقان مع فكرة أنه يمكنك أخذ
المقعد الأوسط من  طائرة
ولديها أي نوع من الاقتباس ، يعد التباعد الاجتماعي
أمرًا سخيفًا ، ولا يمكنك استخدامه
لأعمال التباعد الاجتماعي
عندما يكتمل.  ربما تكون الطائرات نظيفة
بشكل أفضل ، نعم ، سيكون ذلك جيدًا على أي حال ، لكن
التباعد الاجتماعي في هذه الأنواع من
الساحات هو
أسطورة أعطتنا شركة تصميم المقصورة الإيطالية Aveo
interiors لمحة عما
يمكن أن يبدو عليه المستقبل مثل هذا الدرع الذي
يمكن تركيبه على المقاعد الحالية.
الحاجز بين الركاب لزيادة
العزلة ، والإصلاح الداخلي الأكثر تطرفًا
يقلب المقعد الأوسط
تمامًا للحفاظ على الاتصال بين
الركاب على الأقل للتأكد من
إعادة فتح صناعة السفر وسننقل
إلى الهواء مرة أخرى ولكن بالنسبة
للركاب مثلك ومثلي
التجربة  نمر قد لا
نكون نفس الشيء مرة أخرى لريتشارد كويست
سي إن إن نيويورك